[Music]
let's find
Larry let's find
[Music]
Larry well hello
there my name
is my name is findo I love finding
people it's fun let me introduce you to
some of the controls
go ahead and press a or D on your
keyboard ah I
see you just made the whole world spin
that's great I feel like I'm going to
hurl yeah rotating is great for finding
New Perspective to look from only one
more thing o I missed
it hey down here it's me so if this
looks familiar and this is let's fine
Larry by the way
it's made by the same people or person
that made night of the consumers so that
can give you a lot of an idea of the
style it must be pretty tough to see me
from all the way up there press right
Mouse button to zoom
in wow now click on me with the left
Mouse
button
whoa you're a natural well you're all
sent to go I'm going to I missed it
again click on that bit old arrow in the
corner and f f all right I will thank
you
findo have
love what a beautiful
day I went to go take a walk in the park
and then I saw him I never forgot his
face my best friend from high school
Larry he's the Talk of the Town we
haven't seen each other in years it's
great to see you Larry it sure is is is
that Larry is that supposed to be Larry
not exactly hard to
find joint you found Larry oh
boy you know the longer you stare at
Larry's face the more something um like
a secondary face kind of appears thanks
Larry I'll see you around
buddy so um what happens if I don't find
Larry
that's not Larry well that's definitely
not Larry well that's sure not Larry I
don't know who that guy
is oh there he is you found Larry it's a
beautiful day isn't it sure is Larry I
have a good feeling
oh wow well this
is you chubby cheek bastard look at you
you
are horrifying okay Larry Larry wow wait
is that Larry is that that's not Larry
is it no that just looks like
Larry
Larry Larry oh oh oh oh I see you you
found I got you
Larry all right I'll see you
around if it wasn't clear this is one of
those games that's probably going to
take a dark turn and I eagerly look
forward to it Larry where are you
Larry Larry I got oh there he is I got
to employ the technique that lifeguards
do and just scan up and down constantly
actually it's kind of the same uh thing
I do when I play uh observation
Duty where you at
Larry where you at oh oh there you are I
wouldn't have been able to find you from
that
perspective maybe if I just quickly swap
swap
swap what are you doing half buried in
the ground there buddy you okay you okay
pal there are a few more people that
look like Larry but there's only one OG
Larry that wouldn't be him would it
[Music]
no oh oh oh there oh there he
is that should have been easier to find
I don't know why it took me so long is
that confetti or is that bacteria or
something like that growing in the other
screens there okay let me check the
Outer Perimeter first okay check this
circle
uh that's not Larry oh of course right
there you found Larry are you following
me well yes absolutely do you have a
problem with that are you going to have
a problem with that because I'm going to
have a problem with
you oh that was easy you hi Larry what
was
that there was something in the bottom
right corner right there something else
I don't know what that
was well this isn't exactly
oh
[Music]
oh got him found Larry hi Larry you
you're not looking so good you all right
good great good to hear um
okay what is that what is with you okay
that's probably fine
oh you're fine there all is
well um he's a little trickier this time
unless I'm just crazy this is a little
UNC my goodness you are a be look at
you
uh again I I'm not a 100% sure what's
going on with this guy
here it's a little
strange
oh oh was it no that's not him in there
you can't hide
Larry I'm going to find
you oh oh there he is a I didn't suspect
that he wouldn't be out of the buildings
gotcha you found Larry hey quit it I
don't think I will and even if I could I
I don't know
how oh well this is
peculiar um well you guys don't seem
like Larry but there is a Larry right
there you found Larry stop following me
or I'll call the
fuzz something tells me you won't
something tells me there's a dark secret
to you that you don't want the police to
know about oh well let's a little
[Music]
convenient you found Larry help somebody
stalker
stalker probably actually you know this
does seem I didn't I didn't ask a
question of why I was going to do this
you found Larry
[Music]
please
mhm is that the mall I love the mall and
I love consumption you found Larry I
[Music]
did mhm okay this wouldn't be Larry
wearing this mask here would it you're
not Larry are
[Music]
you oh oh wait a minute Larry you
thought you could hide you found Larry
not today Larry not today not when I'm
in charge am I in charge probably
not oh hi Larry you found Larry I did
man the the populace is getting a little
oh uh-huh I can't rotate in this
one oh
ah
uh-huh
oh
uh-huh oh wait was that Larry over there
gotcha you found
Larry
no I don't know who them is but I'm me
and I did that take two presses to do hi
Larry what you doing in
there won you found Larry I
did I feel like that maybe
oh thought I saw Larry for a second
there okay well this going to be
slightly
trickier
huh that oh I got him I got him I got
him ah ah ah
oh uh you all right
Larry you found
Larry okay you know you can't hide from
the floating de that's circling over
ahead uh no matter how much you try
always going to find
[Music]
you
oh all right you in one of these windows
[Music]
Larry
Larry oh oh oh I can't oh I can't I
don't want to zoom
in really don't want
to oh I can't zoom out oh oh oh hi Larry
oh where you going
buddy
uh I don't think that's how cars work
but what do I know
ah is this the them I've heard so much
about
[Music]
uh-huh oh I still can't
rotate oh hi hello how are you good
you're the one that I saw on
the
ah
[Music]
okay
hi my what lovely gums you
have ah yes notice you've been keeping a
close eye on
somebody
yep we like finding people too recognize
this
right oh nice guy Larry once again the
popular local middlewood resident is
being honored by the mayor for his
several acts of kindness read more about
it on page two I know he's close I can
smell him we would like a little word
with him he's a slippery s
so proven to be difficult to track down
but you seem to be doing just fine I'm
not somebody who wants to upset stay on
his tail if you know what's good for me
you will lead us right to
him
thanks um lar oh oh weird oh Larry's
that's oh yeah
mhm well bye
Larry oh boy I need to be I hear that uh
pizza for breakfast pizza for
breakfast Larry
Larry listen Larry ah I have something
to tell you graffiti graffiti nice I
have something to tell you Larry I
really need to talk to you some serious
business is going
down oh
ah I
see uhhuh
interesting Larry you think you can hide
this isn't how this goes Larry isn't
here Larry isn't
here there he
was oh Larry this is unto
Ward
[Music]
H Larry isn't here weird Larry isn't
here
no fascinating that's a lot of x's I
feel like that's more X's than any one
person could possibly handle hey wait a
minute hi
Larry you saw them didn't
you
listen they they took my family they
took them I don't know what they've done
and now they're coming for me they're
Relentless anywhere I go they always
follow me they'll never stop no no no no
no there's no Escape help me please I'm
going to
die all right calm down there
buddy they're
here
well if you ask nicely I suppose I can't
help it help you oh oh oh SS like I know
where they're going to
be uh yeah Larry I don't know how I can
help you they kind of seem to
have point out where he's hiding do it
now or what you know I may not like this
Larry guy but you're not the boss of me
I don't take orders from
nobody Larry is right there he's in
there in there looking at boobies and
stuff oh drinking triple XX
moonshine I can't believe
[Music]
it
Larry man I just don't know where Larry
could
be well I guess there's nothing else to
do
huh Larry you found Larry oh boy hi
Larry Hey listen it's nothing personal
um I I I tried the whole going into the
strip club thing it didn't work oh
goodbye oh we're in
in hi hello hey what's up how are yall
doing fine evening here lovely lovely
evening hi Larry you found Larry yes I
did hi Larry listen um I know you're
having a good time in the pile uh but
there's some fine folks that want to
have a word with you uh so if you could
just step out into the
open I would be able
to go on with my day where are you Larry
Larry
[Music]
oh
Larry Larry
good
God all right thanks Larry
[Music]
sorry
uh-huh this is um is that blood I got
more questions but I mean I know it said
there was like 15 X's outside but at the
same time I feel like this is far too
many uh-huh okay Larry it's a bit of an
overreaction at this point you know if
they took your family and they want to
take you I'm assuming that means you're
going to go to where your family is
isn't that kind of like what you
want come on Larry think about
it you found Larry I sure
did
Larry oh I see you there Larry um
so what's the deal
Larry you found Larry Larry this is
getting a little embarrassing for both
of us it's mostly for
you hi
Larry oh
hi good job thanks the fool has ran into
a building up ahead we got him trapped
on the rooftop this is the night boys
you'll be able to get a nice clean shot
on him from up there take this you found
50 caliber sniper rifle I sure
did uh uh
interesting yep all right
[Laughter]
uh ah I see
um hi Larry listen um this is hardly
what I would call personal click clack
where are you going Larry where are you
going where are you Larry you're not
running around are you
Wham
clack
clack click
wow Larry
listen you
bastard all
right oh
boy I know where he
is I know oh clack clack click click
nice one kid uh-huh you don't know how
long we've been after this mother
uh-huh we got you trapped now no Escape
you've been hiding for long enough I've
dedicated half of my life to hunting you
down time's up Wily Mac Willy Mac but
I'm just Larry cut the take it off
you son of a when I heard the fuzz
caught you and put you behind bars it
was the worst day of my life cuz I
thought this moment would never come out
the moment where I put a bullet through
your sick
skull clack clack
Larry
click click
[Applause]
w
oh I I probably should have taken
another shot I
guess yeah I guess that was was that
like a quick time thing where I was
supposed to take another Kaboom uh cuz I
could have and I thought about it but I
what is with the big
Arrow I I don't know what that's
about
okay oh good
very opportune light
okay you couldn't just leave me alone
could you Larry Larry it's me your
friend from high
school I thought I had a good thing on
until you came along and ruined
everything looks like I need to close
eyes I wonder if you scream is my seat
oh oh oh hey waa
Larry oh oh wait a minute now this isn't
fair wait a minute wait a minute hold on
a second wait a minute
I I don't
agree I didn't scream as much as he
distressing news coming from the quiet
town of middlewood this morning yeah
where a dismembered body of a man was
discovered today in middlewood Park
uhhuh the police cordoned off the park
and discovered trash bags that had been
buried underground uhhuh trash bags
containing severed body parts uhhuh
attempts to identify the body have
proven difficult as the authorities
state that the face of the man had been
removed yeah the police are asking for
anyone to step forward with any
information or anyone who might have
seen or heard anything middlewood Park
between the hours of 8:00 a.m. and 9:00
a.m. the extreme graphic nature of this
crime Bears an uncanny resemblance to
the wiie mack murders that haunted the
town for many years uhuh Willie Mack
notorious for the murder and mutilation
of 17 people between 1996 and
1999 some of the most graphic of the
murders committed in the town of
middlewood in the year 2001 he was
apprehended and sentenced to life in
prison
uhhuh although only last year Mr Mack
was presumed dead when a prisoner
transport vehicle relocating him crashed
and burst into flames ah the middlewood
police will be issuing a statement
shortly but for now we go over to Tom
for the weather away Tom
Tom I hate this job okay uh Tom
oh yes thanks Jerry it's it's going to
be a beautiful day folks Sunny spells
all
around yeah all right well hey it's a
good
ending I don't know if there's multiple
endings cuz I don't really think there
was anything else for me to do except
maybe take that shot but I even then I
don't know if I could
have but hey there you
[Music]
go
uh-oh
[Music]
uh what was that lixian
analyze analyze harder analyze harder
and come to a
conclusion come
on